y en directo Vamos hasta Ecuador para
hablar con nuestro corresponsal Gustavo
Ortega sobre el caso de María Belén
Beltrán quien fue encontrada sin vida en
un cerro cercano de la escuela superior
de policía en el norte de quito el
último lugar al que la mujer acudió para
visitar a su pareja quien figura como el
principal sospechoso y ahora se
encuentra prófugo el gobierno
ecuatoriano solicitó a la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos que
supervisa la investigación sobre el caso
una comisión de expertos desde Colombia
también era parte de estas pesquisas
Gustavo muy buenas noches cuéntenos
Quién era María Belén Y por qué su caso
ha generado tanta conmoción y reacciones
en la opinión pública
Sí muy buena noche para ti María Belén
Bernal era una abogada 34 años que fue
encontrada muerta luego de haber sido
denunciada como desaparecida había sido
el presidente de la república quien dio
la noticia de su fallecimiento y esto
sucede luego que habría ingresado a la
escuela superior de la policía María
Belén Bernal deja un niño de 13 años de
edad ella Trabajaba en un bufete de
abogados con seis mujeres y básicamente
se enfocaba a casos en materia penal
Pero porque el caso genera tanta
reacción en la opinión pública bueno
básicamente porque María Belén Bernal
fue desaparecida de la escuela superior
de la policía fue ahí donde se le vio
por última vez para ir a visitar a su
esposo a la 1:30 de la mañana
posteriormente fue su mamá la que puso
la denuncia de su desaparición y
posteriormente hay otros puntos que
también han llamado a la opinión pública
de la conmoción ha habido movilizaciones
por parte de movimientos feministas en
cuanto manejo de este caso De igual
forma también el ministro Carrillo
ministro de interior ha reconocido como
un fallo de seguridad De igual forma
también el presidente de la república
también ha ordenado la renuncia de todos
los altos mandos policiales y la
desvinculación de los cuerpos policiales
de dos generales y De igual forma a
estos dos generales no se les puede
vincular penalmente porque no tienen
relación con la desaparición Pero si por
omisión de algunos protocolos recordemos
que
el teniente Cáceres principal El
sospechoso fue la persona que se le
atribuye la el asesinato de María Belén
Bernal Andrés
Gustavo ahora Cuáles han sido otras de
las principales reacciones sobre este
caso
bueno otra de las reacciones por parte
de los movimientos feministas quien han
exigido justicia De igual forma también
han habido marchas plantones pero para
tener una idea Cuáles son las cifras de
asesinato que se mantienen en Ecuador
hasta la fecha en los primeros seis
meses en Ecuador han fallecido por
violencia de género 138 mujeres y el año
2021 fue el año más violento para las
mujeres habían fallecido 221 mujeres por
violencia de género De igual forma
también la ONU ha dicho de que 65 de
cada 100 mujeres en este país han vivido
un hecho de violencia y De igual forma
el 73% de ella por lo menos han tenido
un vínculo sentimental con las personas
que en la mató en este sentido también
ya El Ejecutivo nacional reconoce que
para poder mantener la transparencia de
la investigación ha convocado a una
comisión internacional y De igual forma
como tú lo has dicho visitará una
comisión de el vecino país de Colombia
para adelantar así las investigaciones
pero todavía falta Que aparezca el
principal sospechoso quién es su esposo